comedy and Media Matters and there's no
way you can say that it doesn't matter
and it affects things it so I know that
has an impact but at the same time I'm
just because you can find a person who's
truly and genuinely offended by what you
say does that make it wrong you only
mean except then at what point can you
say anything hey uh welcome to another
episode of is this okay where we talk
about things and ask the question is
this really okay today we are discussing
when is something considered offensive
verse funny and how do you personally
draw that line I do believe that PC is
killing comedy in a way because I feel
like jokes should be like she's kind of
striking be funny
they invites conflict a hundred percent
that's just the personality that goes
into it and they just write jokes to get
people to react my whole thing about
like being PC and like Oh like you need
to not offend people and you need to
like trier that's not hurt people I
don't think that's too much to ask of
comedians as a community person you
realize there's a lot of gray you might
get to a point where you're like you
know what I'm always gonna offend
somebody and then because of that you
then just go [ __ ] it and I do think that
like there is still something honorable
about at least trying to navigate it if
you try to be sensitive but you also
know you can't please everybody wait
what was the one you had what was the
example that you had thought of so
yeah this is where I draw my line Amy
Poehler is the executive producer of
difficult people's I love that show yeah
I don't watch it but there was a joke
on the show Julie the main character
tweeted something along the lines of
like I can't wait for our Kelly to piss
on blue items like adorably why being
old enough so arguer can piss on her
yeah and she was kind of like you know
like I did this mean tweet but I don't
understand why like everyone's so mad at
me not you're looking at the wrong
person I think you're looking at blue
ivy and you're like oh I hear this word
I think of an infant you shouldn't be
looking at our Kelly who peed on a
person exploitation of its art Kelly who
I mean arguably a bad dude that pisses
on minors things like if I was beyond
saying that was my daughter there made a
joke about peeing on my daughter I'd be
a how I love Beyonce blue think a lot of
like really great power makes the way
they subvert PC culture is making it
that much clearer that this is my
opinion and I do not take myself
seriously none of them take themselves
seriously oh you think that's tough
though because I have a hard time
listening to a comedian he makes a
really smart witty social commentary
comment and I can't lie that so much of
why I like it is because I'm like god
that's such a good point so I can't give
you that love and then the next thing
you saved it oh but nothing he says
matters you're a problematic person in
your everyday life and I don't know if I
can really support you as a comedian
right
I love offensive jokes i watch Margaret
Cho and I watch Kathy Griffin's they
both have really offensive jokes but
they're done in a way that is a lot more
smart and it actually like that is
something about our society think that
if you're gonna make fun of something
that
is sensitive it should be really witty
and be like kind of offensive but it was
so creative and so well worded that was
funny so is it basically for you if it's
as long as it's funny it's not offensive
no because there's some things that like
Eddie Murphy comic comedic icon like
opens up his act
bashing gay people essentially and I'm
like whoa for me watching it it was
extremely hurtful it feels harsh I'm
like maybe you shouldn't be we wouldn't
be saying these things we are to this
day and it depends on who's saying that
joke to like a Latino person talking
about the Latino experience and kind of
making fun of our culture and making it
funny like you're like that's funny
that's cool just have to I mean if it's
coming from even if it was coming from
like if I heard a bunch of a white guy
you're that would make you more mad to
any kind of but it would if he got the
funny things about black people
you wouldn't be oh this is the exact
same reaction I would have it's a black
male but at the same time if you come at
up if you come out of place where it is
like we I feel like you are with me
instead of against me Ali Wong and bill
burr are like two of my favorites I know
for example when bill burr says some
things funny how I can listen to him say
the same joke and some one night I'm
like I didn't feel like you had as much
hatred coming behind that and then other
times I'm like that [ __ ] there was a lot
of hatred behind that I just hope that I
don't feel like I wasted my money
I just want to laugh
people are learning from each other
everyday right and it's a dialogue that
we just we just have to be open with
each other and just learn you understand
that it's Bray but I always lean on can
I feel what your real intent is if I can
feel that your real intent is not
malicious it matters a lot to me to be
further like in certain times intention
does not matter if it hurts somebody via
the people's her feelings are valid how
about you joke is a joke is a joke right
good ones you know like a lot of a lot
of the times it is the better the joke
the the more you'll get away with I'm
just a big fan of jokes okay guys so
when does comedy become too offensive
leave your comments below and we'll see
you next week yours answers on it so
much cooler than I could joke a joke
[Music]